tja und tödliche schüsse die kommen
natürlich auch oft aus schützengräben
unser kollege philipp potthoff der hatte
die gelegenheit in genauso einem
verlassenen russischen schützengraben zu
drehen und es sind wirklich unfassbare
bilder die er von dort mitgebracht hat
nach dem raschen abzug russischer
truppen rücken die ukrainischen
streitkräfte langsam vor indem sie
einzelne dörfer sorgfältig räumen dabei
wir deutlich russisches militär hat
wiederholt unbewaffnete menschen in
deren häusern oder auf offener straße
erschossen und gefoltert auch in der
nähe des dorfes christofori kanal
nikolaev waren bis zu 3000 russische
soldaten stationiert bild reporter
philipp potthoff hat ihren
schützengräben gefunden können uns
einmal diesen russischen schützengraben
anschauen hier im tv sieht man das
hinten liegt müll also konservendosen
und verpackung alles was die russischen
soldaten in dieser zeit zu sich genommen
haben laufen wir einmal
an diesem schützengraben entlang
das ist so eine der zentralen straßen
dieses dorf ist hier sehr viel
militärtechnik durchgekommen panzer
alles mögliche was die russen hatten das
berichten uns anwohner tja und so sieht
ein russischer schützengraben aus hier
mit abdeckung die ihr könnt man
rausschauen durchschießen tja unten ist
alles zugemüllt und
hier waren mehrere wochen lang russische
soldaten bis sie eben vertrieben wurden
von der ukrainischen armee abgezogen
sind aber ganz viele bewohner die auch
hier schreckliches erlebt haben trauen
sich nicht zu sprechen weil sie nicht
wissen ob die russen womöglich wieder
kommen tja und wenn man dann mit der
ausländischen presse gesprochen hat und
die russen das rausfinden dann fürchten
die bewohner dass es dann noch schlimmer
wird die russischen truppen hinterließen
große müllberge entlang der landstraßen
zeichen eines hastigen aufbruchs